[Musica]
Inizierei citando Italo Calvino mi piace
sempre iniziare un ragionamento perché
in nel suo romanzo palomare lui parte da
quella che è la bottega dei formaggi e
questo signore che rimane vicino a
palomarche rimane affascinato da tutti
questi formaggi presenti nella bottega
forme colori particolari posizione e
caratteristiche degli animali
caratteristico ognuna dice che dietro
ogni formaggio C'è un cielo C'è un prato
c'è un animale e soprattutto c'è anche
un uomo che trasmette dietro tutte
queste tradizioni ora Calvino in questo
romanzo si riferiva in particolare alla
Francia ma mi sembra che se ci guardiamo
intorno per quanto riguarda l'aspetto
ambiente è decisamente un ambiente unico
abbiamo in termini di biodiversità
vegetale delle caratteristiche di
unicità nell'arco Alpino in Valle
D'Aosta siano esse per le
caratteristiche dei Ricardi Pascoli e di
pratiche salutiamo La variabilità
floreale ma abbiamo anche una
variabilità dal punto di vista animale
noi nel nostro territorio è presente
un'unica razza che hai presente il
nostro territorio che la razza
valdostana che è vincolata anche tra
l'altro per la produzione dei prodotti
tipici del territorio e abbiamo anche
una biodiversità che non vediamo che non
si può vedere che è la biodiversità
microbica che è quella che dà quelle
caratteristiche di unicità al prodotto
come diceva grazie alla presentazione mi
occupo di Io ho avuto una carriera un
po' particolare perché nasco come
geometra mi occupo di chimica
industriale per poi approdare alle
produzioni animali che sono il mio primo
amore che continuo ovviamente a
sfruttare e a portare avanti ho iniziato
occuparmi a lavorare nel mondo della
filiera della carne ho lavorato nel
mondo Finalmente il mondo della
trasformazione attivo case aree e in
estensione anche quelle che sono in
generale le fermentazioni alimentari
siano esse di origine
vegetali siano esse di origine animale
voglio raccontarvi una storia che inizia
diverse migliaia di anni fa quando i
primi pastori si resero conto che gli
altri che utilizzavano per i trasporti
del latte che non erano nient'altro che
stomaci di mammiferi ruminanti a un
certo punto vuoi per la temperatura vuoi
per lo sbattimento Quando arrivavano il
latte non era più il liquido ma aveva
cambiato aspetto aveva preso un'altra
forma si era diviso e aveva preso
un'altra forma un po' più delicata che
era la cagliata ora capire cosa è stato
Ci sono voluti diversi secoli Ma questo
è stato l'incipit iniziale che ha dato
origine a quella che è tutta la
tecnologia di trasformazione del
formaggio ovviamente è stata sviluppata
nei secoli da popolazioni che ci hanno
messo tantissimo del loro in primis gli
etruschi ci sono seguiti dai Romani i
greci hanno dato anche la loro Il loro
Il loro il loro lavoro ma poi anche i
monaci dei monasteri hanno fatto un
grandissimo lavoro di messa a punto
allora
perché dico questo sostanzialmente
praticamente si è scoperto che di fatto
il formaggio non è nient'altro che un
modo per conservare il latte se ci
pensate un latte sia il suo crudo o
comunque pastorizzato a una chef Life
una durata una vita che dura 6 giorni
mentre un formaggio può durare
tantissimo tempo ci sono formaggi che
hanno anche più di cent'anni per citare
una bella citazione che mi piace citare
sempre è che dice che il formaggio è il
percorso del latte verso l'immortalità
ed è vero Tra l'altro detta da
un'economista Quindi è una è un aforisma
estremamente interessante che spiega
quello che è l'importanza di questo
prodotto Ma questi
i primi operatori avevano capito che
c'era qualcosa che interveneva nella
trasformazione latte in formaggio e
hanno cercato di capire quali erano
quelle azioni che gli andavano a
scomporre o ricomporre o viceversa
quelli che erano i componenti del latte
il latte come tutti gli alimenti è fatto
di componenti che hanno tutti gli altri
Quindi le proteine sono grassi ci sono
ci sono zuccheri il lattosio nello
specifico ci sono sali minerali e
vitamine in diverse percentuali
Ovviamente quella più componenti più
importante è l'acqua ora Cosa succede
quando si trasforma il latte in
formaggio Beh avviene un'azione
soprattutto in primis sulle Casine che
trasforma si forma un reticolo che a sua
volta ingloba del grasso e del Sio che
verrà poi espulso è lo stesso concetto
di quando si fa la panificazione si crea
in quel caso il reticolo con il glutine
che ingloba in quel caso lì aria Quindi
ora in questo caso
questa azione avviene a rispetto alle
proteine
e abbiamo un'azione con una sostanza che
si chiama enzima che è il caglio che è
stato presente in tutti noi quando
eravamo lattanti che permette al
mammifero lattante di poter digerire le
proteine del latte altrimenti non
sarebbero possibile digerirle Guardate
una banalissima azione immaginate una
lunghissima catena che grazie a questa
forbice viene tagliata solo un pezzo e
grazie a questo il latte da liquido
diventa semi solido diventa più
digeribile per il lattante Beninteso Ma
poi da origine a tutta quella che è la
trasformazione attivo casearia ora
quindi abbiamo l'azione del Caglio il
caglio può essere estratto sia dallo
stomaco degli animali da tanti ma può
anche essere di origine vegetale in
tantissimi paesi in Italia in
particolare nel centro e sud ci sono
tantissimi formaggi a cardio vegetale La
Spagna ha un'antissima tradizione di
formaggi a caglio vegetale il Portogallo
lo è ancora di più hanno scoperto che
effettivamente le sostanze che venivano
utilizzate per fare che vengono
utilizzate Scusate per fare il caglio
hanno anche degli effetti
benefici sulla salute sia tanti anni
infatti andiamo a vedere che molte volte
questi prodotti sono si trovano quelle
che sono considerate considerate le zone
blu cioè zone dove l'aspettativa di vita
è molto più lunga rispetto normale che e
quindi sicuramente l'alimentazione gioca
un ruolo estremamente fondamentale
dicevamo l'azione del Caglio che come vi
dicevo diverse origini avviene sulle
proteine ma l'azione può essere anche la
coagulazione può essere anche di origine
acida per azione di qualche cosa che
sono i batteri lattici che sono
estremamente importanti sono presenti
praticamente ovunque
la forma di vita dei batteri è una delle
vite più affascinanti Probabilmente la
più antica ed è diffusa anche in buona
parte del sistema solare oltre che sul
nostro territorio Allora dicevamo La
fermentazione la coagulazione acida È
quella che avviene nello yogurt quindi
in questo caso non è l'azione del Caglio
dell'enzima ma l'azione dei batteri
lattici Che cosa fanno mangiano lo
zucchero lo scindono e gli zuccheri
semplici componenti il lattosio e quindi
lo rendono digeribile perché un sacco di
gente purtroppo intollerante al lattosio
e allo stesso tempo che producono acido
lattico quindi di fatto Cosa fanno non
fanno nient'altro che aumentare
l'acidità del prodotto questo momento di
acidità che è un ambiente sfavorevole a
quelli che sono i microrganismi che sono
alteranti nei confronti degli alimenti
quindi permettono una conservazione
Tant'è vero che se come vedete lo yogurt
come sapete lo yogurt si conserva per
tantissimo tempo Teoricamente la sua
vita è di un mese ma volendo può andare
anche oltre È chiaro che la sua chef
Life è stata stabilita per dargli una
certa quantità di batteri lattici che
apportano all'organismo ma teoricamente
uno yogurt si può mangiare anche più
avanti se non è contaminato da muffe
perché è proprio che è un ambiente
estremamente acido i batteri lattici
vengono anche utilizzati durante la
classificazione dei formaggi perché
perché danno un'azione in aiuto al
Caglio quindi creano un ambiente
sfavorevole acidifica in un ambiente e
danno una mano a lavorare al Caglio
lavorare sulle proteine per poi
scomporle e ricreare il creare il
formaggio o questi batteri lattici però
non hanno solo prestazioni hanno anche
un importante azione durante la durante
la trasformazione tecnologica Beninteso
ma anche soprattutto durante la
stagionatura creano soprattutto un sacco
di profili aromatici diversi che danno
quelle caratteristiche di unicità a un
prodotto Ok
oltretutto
permettono appunto aiutano anche la
conservazione e creano in alcuni casi se
non sono producono più prodotti anche
del gas Le famosi occhi del formaggio
buchi chiamati come volete comunque gli
occhi del formaggio non è nient'altro
che del gas Ok prodotto dei batteri
ma non solo
Quindi cosa abbiamo fatto nel nostro
territorio
a un certo punto negli anni 90 nel
nostro Istituto hanno capito una cosa le
condizioni del latte erano cambiate
cambiano rapidamente Purtroppo le
condizioni di latte hanno cambiate
c'è una bellissima Mi piace citarla e la
voglio citare la tesi del Canonico
votano uno dei fondatori dell'Istituto
riconosciuto in Valle D'Aosta come uno
di quelli che ha portato la viticoltura
in Valle D'Aosta ma in realtà la sua
tesi nel 56 l'ha fatta sui batteri
lattici in fontina 1956 università
Cattolica di Piacenza quindi un testo
Praticamente per quanto mi riguarda un
testo sacro Perché Perché un altro mondo
molto semplicemente è un altro mondo il
latte cambia sovente noi ragioniamo
ovviamente dal punto di vista dell'homo
sapiens quelli che siamo e ragioniamo
sempre dal nostro punto di vista la vita
Noi abbiamo per scontato che una
generazione avviene ogni 25 30 anni più
o meno siamo così ma per i batteri
parliamo di 20 minuti 25 30 minuti
quindi capite bene che in una giornata
può essere passati centinaia di anni in
termini di scala evolutiva Quindi a un
certo punto di vista una capacità di
adattamento che è unica quindi dicevamo
cosa hai capito cosa hanno capito i miei
colleghi di Allora hanno capito che
oltre le condizioni lattico cambiate
Bisognava anche mantenere la tipicità e
come si faceva capire come era la
tipicità Beh Hanno cominciato messo
insieme una grossa squadra che
raccoglieva i tecnici ed Assessorato
l'istituto diverse università e diverse
competenze in giro per l'Italia e hanno
hanno girato tutti quei luoghi
tradizionali dove ne venivano utilizzati
nessun tipo di batteri commerciali
industriali e hanno cercato di capire
cosa c'era Quindi sono andati a
analizzare le mani delle delle degli
operatori che mungevano le mani dei
Casari la i prodotti che venivano
utilizzati in caseificio l'ambiente
stalla l'ambiente latte e l'ambiente e
formaggio Le cantine di stagionatura
Quindi tutta la filiera e alla fine cosa
cosa hanno trovato hanno sono andati a
identificare una serie di Ceppi
batterici che danno caratteristiche di
unicità di tipicità al nostro prodotto
che è la Fontina in questo in questo
caso specifico
Noi siamo usciti a stoccarle sono già a
disposizione presso il nostro Istituto
in una c'è ipoteca che non è diventato
un frigo 80 sotto zero i ceppi in
purezza vengono conservati lì stanno lì
e vengono mantenuti al freddo e per
mantenere la tipicità Ma noi da questi
Ceppi siamo andati a ulteriormente ad
alimentare Se volete vi faccio vedere
Giusto per intenderci Questa è una
bustina di batteri lattice autorizzati
da fontina di cui Ceppi che sono stati
ritrovati questa piccola quantità che mi
metto sulla mano e che faccio volare in
aria circa un grammo abbiamo in questo
grammo di batteri lattici Ci sono circa
un centinaio di miliardi di colonie di
batteri quindi capite bene che anche in
termini di dimensioni sono decisamente
diversi
Noi l'abbiamo mantenuti li abbiamo
tenuti abbiamo voluti conservare ma
abbiamo fatto un lavoro abbiamo esteso
allargato ancora di più il lavoro siamo
andati a fare il stesso lavoro Per il
lato l'altra dopo valdostana che è il
Valle d'aostaformato dopo ma abbiamo
fatto anche dell'Innovazione
percepipi che abbiamo conservato e
abbiamo trovato siamo riusciti a mettere
appunto un latte fermentato non possiamo
chiamarlo yogurt perché la legislazione
italiana fortunatamente estremamente
rigida non possiamo chiamarlo yogurt ma
l'abbiamo chiamato
joalp frutto di un lavoro di un progetto
di collaborazione tipica con gli
svizzeri quindi un lavoro di ricerca
dove le mie colleghe del laboratorio
sono andato ultimamente
caratterizzarlo anche del punto di vista
dei benefici un prodotto nuovo diverso
completamente legato al territorio ok
Quindi quel famoso discorso che vi
dicevo prima Vedete che noi l'abbiamo
famoso discorso si scomporre scomporre
di come si fa un prodotto da tiro
casellario l'abbiamo declinato sui
nostri prodotti abbiamo esteso
ulteriormente i cibi fermentati
ruolo fondamentale oggi e non lo dico io
certo ma lo dice la scienza medica Anche
perché abbiamo visto che di fatto sono
già pre digeriti aiutano tantissimo il
nostro microbiota intestinale nella
digestione
concludo Se volete dicendo riprendendo
un po' quella che è la citazione di
Calvino iniziale Ma allargandola che
oltre a
dietro un buon formaggio oltre al parco
al pascolo all'animale all'uomo che
gioca un ruolo fondamentale sempre ci
stanno anche dei sapori dei profumi e
degli odori Questo è uno strumento che
utilizzo come per il mio lavoro è un
permette di martellare formaggi e di
sentirne la struttura della pasta ma
allo stesso tempo permette di forarli
per vedere come sono fatti dentro e
soprattutto
sentirne i profumi gli odori sprigionati
da quelli che sono i batteri lattici vi
ringrazio